[Música]
chega até vocês de maneira muito humilde
de forma despretensiosa sabendo que nós
já temos opiniões formadas sobre tudo e
sobre todos
e aqui nós vamos tentar dialogar um
pouco sobre os destinos difíceis ea
capacidade de superação desses destinos
para isso nós precisamos ir aos fatos
a vida é construído através dos fatos
dos acontecimentos e para pensando qual
a história mais bonita que eu poderia
compartilhar com você e eu preciso
também valorizar esse momento a minha
história porque o seu não valorizá lá
quem é que vai
e aí eu viajo na linha do tempo para
falar do menino paulo henrique dele
corre lá no mês de novembro de 1973
naquele prostíbulo a cidade de nova
londrina no interior do paraná
à noite normalmente essas coisas
acontecem amante o mostra foi lá visitar
a moça realizar um programa com ela
e aconteceu o acidente
um acidente de trabalho sob o olhar do
mundo um acidente de trabalho
qual seja a minha concepção e naquele
momento eu acredito que ver um filme na
cabeça da minha mãe
o que fazer diante daquela gravidez
indesejada ao que acontece todos os dias
nós temos notícia mas em 1983
[Música]
descobri que estava grávida na cidade e
interior
solteira
o rio se o risco dependendo da
localidade se a pedra já é até possível
que alguém cogitou sobre o aborto
vamos interromper esse aí méxico se não
vamos atrás do dna
imagina 73 falar de dna mãe maria
filomena dele cole escolheu me dá a
oportunidade de vir à luz deste mundo
como a sua mãe também te deu essa
oportunidade e aí no mês de julho de
exatamente no dia 23 às 14 30
eu tive a oportunidade de ver a luz
deste mundo
a mãe ganhou alta na enfermaria e eu fui
pra minha primeira casa a casa vermelha
da luz vermelha
o próximo à zona do m e é tão
interessante porque naquele lugar
aparentemente nós píton eu encontrei o
aconchego aconchego de uma mãe mãe
tentou me segurar os braços durante dois
meses mas como criar o menino dentro do
possível ea então ela resolveu buscar
ajuda até que bateu na porta de um
casebre muito humilde ea dona tina
quando abri a porta vê aquele menino
coberto na flauta levanta
e houve a cláudia maria filomena de óleo
na china não tenho eu não tenho condição
de cuidado espírito sempre vem pra mim
eu te ajudo doe uma ajuda do final do
mês com leite um alimento básico ea
santa tina não titubeou e tomou nos
braços aquele menino passou a assumir
também a maternidade afetiva
o marido conta a história que nem sabia
dos acontecimentos
dois adolescentes em casa e de repente
ele vem pra almoçar ele ouviu um choro
de criança e ver aquele livro foi lá e
pergunta de quem é que é
apareceu a moça aí você pegaria o menino
hoje lá daquele lugar do prost pode vir
alguma coisa que preste gente naquela
humilde casa e apresentar jesus me levar
até a casa dele e digo pra vocês
o sujeito é tremendo ele não aponta
dentro ele não faz acusações e te acolhe
e fala de uma maneira extraordinária do
amor como eu nunca ouvi ninguém falar e
se jesus de que tanto se fala e pouco se
conhece tem me ajudado dia a dia me
estruturar a enfrentar os meus fantasmas
emocionais inclusive a respeito da minha
origem o que nega sua origem nega sua
história foi uma farsa e mentira eu tive
que olhar para aquela realidade encara
ela mas o mundo é mau
existe muita maldade também
apesar de que a bondade prepondera nunca
duvide disso a bondade prepondera e já
na minha adolescência descobrir
descobrir o local onde eu tinha sido
concebido
os meninos da minha época e aí então
eles pegaram um punhal uma força de
expressão que para você entender pegar
um punhal bem afiado espetar nas minhas
costas quando ofendiam a honra da minha
mãe biológica pra você
ela pode até ser uma prostituta mas pra
mim ela é a minha mãe é sagrado
ela tem um valor inegociável no meu
coração
no meu entendimento espanhol chegava no
íntimo da minha alma e mutilava e eu
chegava desfigurado em casa
nessa época já na minha adolescência eu
comecei a compreender o que era
prostituição e eu comecei a ficar com
nojo de mim mesmo
nós da minha pele nojo do meu sangue
passou pela minha cabeça até umas idéias
loucas aí até questionar por que é que a
minha mãe não havia abortado
ou ainda bem que um dia desses eu li em
atos dos apóstolos no livro sagrado
no capítulo 17 versículo 30 que deus não
leva em conta o tempo da nossa
ignorância
ainda bem que nós temos chance de
salvação
eu estava na minha ignorância como eu
pegar confrontar a minha mãe biológica
por ela ter me dado o bem mais precioso
a dádiva é mais preciosa que a vida e eu
te pergunto você tem confrontado à sua
mãe que tem questionado ela sobre o fato
dela ter dado a oportunidade de você ver
a luz deste mundo
mas digo mais eu me olhava no espelho e
obrigaram o espelho muitas vezes o que
eu queria aparecer
os meus pais afetivos e um espelho me
devolve a imagem natural a imagem dos
meus pais biológicos e o confrontava o
confrontava e teve um lado espero que
até reconheciam lado no espírito até
reconhecido lá da minha mãe mas o lado
do meu pai biológico na economy
conhecendo o que eu vou reconhecer e aí
eu vou avançando dessa história a passos
largos é verdade
[Música]
chegando lá na faculdade através de uma
bolsa de estudos fazer o curso de
direito
descobri o ministério público e de
repente eu estou em minas gerais
e aí no ano de 2013
já atuando como promotor da infância e
juventude e aparece um caso um caso
emblemático esses que você guarda para a
eternidade
um garoto de 13 anos ela tem uma
indisciplina e agressividade na escola
os alunos com os colegas agressividade
com a professora e de repente chega
também a agressividade com a diretora
pronto vamos fazer o relatório dos
garotos e aí vai mandá-la promotor
aqueles sacramente aquilo que
normalmente nós esperamos fazer assepsia
expurgar excluir mais ou menos aquela
teoria do tomate estragado sexta
tira-se tomate embolorado porque senão
ele vai contaminar os demais e aí eu
chamei os garotos na manhã do mês de
abril
e ele chega lá um tanto quanto confiado
deixem as ocorrências de lado e foi
procurar primeiro procurar conhecer que
nós temos esse hábito que está com a
sentença pronta sem mesmo conhecer a
história daquele que está diante de nós
já estamos com a sentença na mão e então
eu peço para me apresentar
ele fala o nome fala cidade que nasceu o
nome da mãe
e quando chega o nome do pai e diz que
nunca tem pai insistiu insistiu
eu falei olha mas até eu sei que tem pai
até eu tenho certeza que existe um pai
biológico
bom a mãe interfere na conversa e e aí
ela explica a situação onde estava com
quatro anos os pais se separaram até
então não tem novidade nenhuma e de
repente agora estava com 13 3 - 49 anos
de ausência quando o pai se separou da
mãe se separou do filho também garoto
foi mergulhando na dor dele e fui
sentindo tive uma vivência ali e ali
naquele momento eu eup as expectativas
que ele criou o dia do aniversário vai
bem no natal época de reconciliação onde
as famílias se reencontram ele vem ano
novo chegou determinado momento que ele
começou a se culpar eu falei ele pensou
que podia ter feito alguma coisa muito
ruim
meu pai virar as costas para mim e eu
falei pra ele olha vamos fazer o
seguinte
obrigado seu pai repente estar
contrariado e envergonhado de chegar
depois de nove anos quando peguei o
telefone começou a tremer com medo de
quem gente a mais a então eu falei não
vou colocar você nessa situação você
anima escreveu a carta de seu pai
colocar tudo para fora e aí
para minha surpresa esse menino rasga o
coração patos de minas 2 de abril de
disse a ele olha você pode falar o que
você quiser inclusive até chegar ao seu
pai
[Música]
e aí então começa chegando o pai dele
querido papai chegou também a coragem de
escrever esta singela card para dizer
que sinto muito a sua falta
você já foi criança um dia quis ter um
pai e uma mãe presente
espero apenas apenas ser reconhecido
como seu filho
nas palavras e nos gestos de amor e para
isso precisamos nos conhecer melhor
papai eu gostaria de ouvir a sua voz
falar com você dividir os meus segredos
as minhas dúvidas e nas lanchonetes nos
campos de futebol ou brincar um pouco
fico por aqui aguardando ansiosamente o
seu contato pelo celular
não se esqueça jamais que apesar da
nossa distância
nunca deixei de te ama
eu achava que estava atendendo os
garotos mas na realidade ele estava me
atendendo naquele momento ali eu
conseguir remover as camas dos olhos e
olhar para o meu pai biológico olhar
para aquela noite ele esteve lá
visitando a mãe ea tomou como mulher
para que uma nova vida exista é preciso
o solo fértil outro da mãe ea semente de
boa qualidade
[Música]
cm
meu pai biológico gente à noite que
papai esteve lá visitando a mãe é a
noite mais abençoado da minha vida eu
tenho uma terna gratidão porque se não
tivesse não estaria aqui contando essa
história
e digo mais se não me reconheceu
eu reconheço meu coração sempre esteve
presente assim como digo que eu
precisava de encontrar fundamentos até
mesmo para passar por cima das minhas
preocupações sobre ofender os meus pais
afetivos porque no meu íntimo eu ficava
preocupado porque seu amásio os meus
pais biológicos estava cometendo um
enorme injustiça com aqueles que me
criaram mas eles só me criar porque os
meus pais biológicos participar desse
projeto de vida
se o mundo um dia me chegou como fruto
do pecado
eu posso lhe assegurar que eu enxergo
como presente de deus
e você também é um presente de deus
não importa de onde você veio
você é aquilo que você quer ser e mais
onde abandonou o pecado superabundou a
graça ea graça transborde nós jamais
desista da vida a vida é o bem mais
precioso que nós temos inclusive que
precisamos cultivar o meu desafio é
chegar até você levar você é essa
reflexão que você já nasceu o vencedor
deixou 299 milhões de indivíduos para
trás os outros espermatozóides que não
ia conseguir chegar e eles estão lá
olhando pra nós agora e perguntando se
está representando nós bem aí porque nós
que gostaríamos de ocupar esse lugar no
tempo e no espaço mas ele foi reservado
pra você e lhe foi reservado pra você e
nós estamos aqui torcendo outro lado que
você conseguiu atravessar o portal da
vida e nós estamos aqui como
espectadores da vida ele possa desta
palavra o seu coração porque o rasgo meu
pra você na expectativa de que você
possa superar a enfrentar todos os seus
fantasmas emocionais ainda que o mundo
tente diminuir depreciar seja pela
condição financeira seja porque você foi
concebido no local não muito
convencional come posse dessa palavra
porque é onde abundou pecado
superabundou a graça diz o autor da
carta aos romanos 5 20 acima de tudo o
amor
o amor é tudo supera tudo e aqui estamos
vivendo e procurando construir uma
inédita história de amor à humanidade
que você faça parte dessa história
também
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]